I haven't done my foot bath in a long time. I did it two days ago and felt sick afterwards.
I felt my throat had a feeling of sickness. I felt like mental detox that I had in the past.
Now I feel like my lungs are struggling et cetera. Should the foot bath have, put the foot bath
have stimulated this? Certainly it could have, certainly it could have just been a coincidence too.
But if you feel that way, okay, so that could be technically what's called a Herkseimer reaction.
A Herkseimer reaction was first described by a doctor, Herkseimer, German doctor.
And since then, people with Lyme disease refer to it often because they
many times inadvertently think that they're having a Herkseimer reaction but they're actually having
an autoimmune reaction but that's another story. So Herkseimer reaction is when you kill
too quickly and or you and you're liberating a lot of endotoxins, which is endotoxins are toxins
from a destruction of a cell line. That's happens in doing chemo because chemo is killing that
through apoptosis but killing through a pathological cell death of necrosis or lysis and you're
liberating endotoxins. You're liberating the cell membrane and all sorts of lysosomes and all
the ribosomes and the innards of the cell that your liver no has to detoxify. Same thing I said,
would you kill bacteria? You're going to liberate endotoxins. You kill bacteria that are
grabbed negative. You're going to liberate the polysaccharides and you're going to have to detoxify
that. Seriously, if you do a foot bath and you feel that way, what does it sign up? If it is
from that, it's a sign of clogged or overwhelmed liver detox pathways. So do a coffee animal. So if
you ever have a you feel like you're having a Herkseimer reaction, what is the treatment? Drink a lot
of water. Do a coffee animal. Okay, here's another example. I went and got a massage. I never
get a massage. I haven't got a massage for years. I went and got this deep tissue massage for an hour
and I felt like I was going to die the next day. I felt sick. It's because you liberated all these
toxins that was overwhelming your liver. What would be the treatment? Drink a lot of water. That's
why your massage therapist would say the same thing. Get a massage. Just drink a lot of water.
Flush these things out. Drink a lot of water. Do a sauna. What would be another thing? Do a coffee
animal. Do a hot pack over your liver or a castor oil with hot pack over your liver. Castor oil
pack with hot pack over your liver. Help support your detoxification pathways. And if you need help
understanding that you guys all have access to my seven phases of detoxification course. So go back
and review the seven phases of detoxification. Are you constipated? Make sure that you're not
constipated. Take some super aloe if you're constipated to unclog yourself. Make sure you're having
good moments. Make sure you're you're binding stuff in the gut and make sure you are supporting
the liver in the bile duct. You could have a clogged blocked bile duct. You could have a full
gall bladder. And that's where hot packs over that area. Castor oil packs over the liver,
gall bladder area and coffee animals come in fashion. So make sure you're supporting all the
phases of detoxification. If it lasts more than a couple of days, it's probably something else
and you probably have a virus because typically a detox reaction, sometimes they're called
Herkseimer reaction is the most common name for them is only in the last day or so. So if it's
lasting more than you probably is just coincidental and you probably have a virus or something. So
that's what way to know.